all right way back in the fall of 2020
the New York Post dared to report the
truth about the hunter Biden Joe Biden
and the laptop from hell it was censored
by the rest of the media with the help
of the FBI warning them that this may be
misinformation but today with possible
charges now looming against Hunter oh
the post was barred from Biden's only
event now this comes as the New York
Post columnist and best-selling author
Miranda Devine is reporting that
Hunter's ex-business partner Devin
Archer who has been convicted of fraud
is now making one last-ditch effort to
avoid prison according to Devin quote or
I'm sorry Miranda Devine quote friends
with knowledge of hunters thinking are
telling Archer to accept that the bidens
have thrown him under the bus and that a
last-minute presidential pardon has been
ruled out she continues quote they have
urged him to save himself by using the
only currency that he has left and that
is his knowledge of the Biden family and
their influence peddling scheme for
which he had a front row seat for four
years during Joe Biden's vice presidency
now for reference this is Devin Archer
golfing with Hunter and Joe and that
photo emerged after Biden swore over and
over and over again during the 26 2020
campaign that he never spoke to his son
about his farm business dealings in
reality Joe met in person with at least
14 of Hunter Biden's Farm business
associates and now with more from the
New York Post Fox News contributor
Miranda Devine I'm sure your feelings
have really heard about being uh uh kept
out of the presser today
well look I I just think it's appalling
obviously we've hit a nerve with the
Biden Administration but it's not their
Press Room it's not Joe Biden's Press
Room it's the people's Press Room for an
Administration that is probably the most
uh untransparent of any in recent memory
and the most opaque and the president
who's the least accessible to do this
should be causing an outrage with the
rest of the media they should boycott
that press room and I think that they're
just quite happy to be sycophants you
saw that at the
um you know the White House
Correspondents Dinner it's embarrassing
the way there are journalists in
Washington who just suck up to this
President they never ask him hard
questions Friday night you had Stephanie
rule on MSNBC soft soaping the interview
with Joe Biden again this is what we see
over and over I don't know what is wrong
with them they're supposed to be doing
their job and they don't and the the
journalists who do their jobs like our
very good Washington correspondent
Stephen Nelson
um get get treated appallingly get
thrown out get excluded unable to ask
questions and frankly the Biden
Administration wants to destroy Fox News
wants to destroy the New York Post and
this is the way they go and it's because
we are the only mainstream media
organizations who are really speaking
truth to power almost 35 years in media
and I am very proud of my record I have
never Miranda went to a single White
House correspondence dinner and that
record will never be it'll only get
larger because I'm never going uh all
right let's talk about that I've been to
a couple yeah you've been talking to a
couple you have my sympathy that I have
no they don't like me and I don't like
them so let's be honest about it it's
fairly straightforward all right let's
talk about Devin Archer his his back is
now against the wall he's got one more
shot as I understand it in terms of
making an appeal the only out for him
would be to cooperate uh that's if they
even allow it to happen
um I'm suspicious of that only because
the justice department and and Justice
in America we have a dual system so I'm
not even sure if that deal would be
available to them uh do you have any
indication he might flip
well look all I know is that on Tuesday
he has his last ditch effort these oral
Arguments for his appeal it's the same
judge judge Sullivan who's part of this
panel who reversed his previous
exoneration by uh judge Abrams and so it
really it's a real long shot that he
would get any relief here and I believe
I'm told that he's feeling despondent
and really feels betrayed by the bidens
I think he had some hope up until now
that
um that he would get a pardon because
after all
um he he's really taken the brunt of uh
the the punishment for a business that
Hunter was involved in as well Hunter
and Devin were joined at the hip
throughout
um you know Joe's vice presidency they
were in barisma together and so on and
so I think that Devin thinks it's quite
unfair that he's the one going to jail
and having to pay 42 million dollars in
restitution and Hunter Biden as usual
gets off scot-free so he felt that he'd
been loyal and um that that that the
bidens should be loyal in return so uh
let's see what happens but I think he
does have information
um that certainly would be as John
Solomon said it would be material to any
attempt to investigate Joe Biden for his
role in this influence peddling scheme
because he's seen it all he's seen Joe
Biden meet the their business partners
from overseas he's seen Joe Biden talk
to them on the phone
um you know he could do a lot and he's
seen it from the start through barisma
through the original China deals
all right Miranda great reporting as
always thank you hey Sean Hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else